I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供独家幕后故事
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi. Hello, hi. Oh, I'm excited for the show today. I am so tickled about today's episode. I just loved it so much. We have a special interview today. It is with our safety meeting queen,
这些只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嗨。哦，你好，嗨。哦，我对今天的节目很兴奋。我对今天的剧集感到非常高兴。我太喜欢它了。今天我们有一个特别的采访。采访对象是我们的安全会议女王，
first AD of the office, Kelly Cantley. Yay. We love getting mail from all of you, asking questions about Phil Shea and his props tray, or about standards and practices, or Bob Dunn's animal rentals. And you know so many of our crew's names. You know the ins and outs of the show now. Yes, you have really gotten as invested in the nuts and bolts of the show as we have.
《办公室》的第一副导演，凯利·坎特利。耶。我们很高兴收到大家发来的邮件，询问关于菲尔·谢伊和他的道具盘，或是关于标准与规范，或是鲍勃·邓恩的动物租赁。而且你们知道我们剧组这么多人的名字。你们现在对节目的方方面面都门清了。是的，你们对这档节目的细枝末节的投入程度确实和我们一样深。
And so we're so excited for you to hear about the making of the office from Kelly's perspective. This interview, oh my gosh, the nuggets. So many nuggets. You know, Kelly was the assistant director for 72 episodes. And she has some story. Oh, does she? She even has more that we wanted to come back and tell.
所以我们非常兴奋能让你们从凯利的视角听到《办公室》的制作过程。这次采访，天哪，干货满满。干货太多了。你知道的，凯利担任了72集的助理导演。她有很多故事。哦，她真的有吗？她甚至还有更多我们希望她回来讲的故事。
When we were getting ready to talk to Kelly, I went in my digital clutter just to see what I could find. And you know what? I found a very funny email. I want to share with you first though, that Kelly Cantley and I are very close in height. We both have blonde hair. And from time to time, if we were on set
当我们准备和凯利交谈时，我翻了翻我的数码杂物箱，看看能找到什么。你知道吗？我找到了一封非常搞笑的邮件。不过我想先告诉你们，凯利·坎特利和我身高非常接近。我们俩都是金发。而且时不时地，如果我们在片场，
and they were trying to figure something out with my character and I wasn't there, they would ask Kelly to stand in. And this is what I found in my digital clutter. I can't wait to bring this up to her. It was from Steve Burgess to me, Kelly and Phil Shea titled Foot Photos, November 16th, 2012. Steve wrote, we took these photos of Kelly's foot today,
他们正试图弄清楚我角色的某些事情而我不在时，他们会让凯利来做替身。这就是我在我的数码杂物箱里找到的。我迫不及待地想向她提起这件事。这是史蒂夫·伯吉斯发给我、凯利和菲尔·谢伊的邮件，主题是《脚部照片，2012年11月16日》。史蒂夫写道，我们今天拍了这些凯利的脚的照片，
wondering if you can contort your foot to look equally as bad. I think Kelly may call you to talk about this foot gag. Phil Shea will see you at 2 p.m. Thanks Steve. I responded with this, I think my foot will do this. And then Phil Shea wrote, okay, great. So Tim will photograph your feet at 2 p.m. Thank you.
想知道你能不能把你的脚扭曲得看起来同样糟糕。我想凯利可能会打电话给你聊聊这个脚部笑话。菲尔·谢伊会在下午2点见你。谢谢，史蒂夫。我回复了这个，我想我的脚可以这样做。然后菲尔·谢伊写道，好的，太棒了。所以蒂姆将在下午2点拍摄你的脚。谢谢。
What is this? And then there are several photos of Kelly's feet and my feet and us trying to get them to do the same things. I was so incredibly curious. I emailed Steve Burgess and asked him what was this about? He shared to me that it was from a runner for customer loyalty that we didn't end up using, and he included a script page. It read like this, Pam walks to the accounting area with her bag. She announces, well, I'm heading to CeCe's recital. Oscar goes, ah, and smiles at Pam for what he feels like is the appropriate amount of time and then drops it and turns back to his computer. Angela says, did I tell you I dance as a child?
这是什么？然后有几张凯利的脚和我的脚的照片，以及我们试图让它们做同样的事情。我太好奇了。我给史蒂夫·伯吉斯发邮件，问他这是怎么回事？他告诉我，这是《客户忠诚度》中一个最终没有被采用的过场情节，他还附上了一页剧本。上面是这样写的：帕姆拿着包走向会计区。她宣布，好吧，我要去参加西西的独奏会了。奥斯卡说，啊，并且以他觉得合适的时间长度对帕姆微笑着，然后就不理了，转回他的电脑前。安吉拉说，我小时候跳过舞吗？
On point by age two. She's very proud. And then she says, it permanently stunted my foot growth. Kevin says, it's true, I can fit her shoe all the way in my mouth. Angela's talking head, she holds up her foot, which is gnarled and small. Then the camera was going to reveal my feet, and Phil Shea would have had to have made a foot prosthetic that was curved and tiny, and this whole entire storyline was cut out.
两岁就脚尖着地了。她非常骄傲。然后她说，这永久地阻碍了我脚部的生长。凯文说，真的，我可以把她的整只鞋塞进嘴里。安吉拉的访谈镜头，她举起一只脚，又畸形又小。然后镜头将展现我的脚，菲尔·谢伊本得制作一个弯曲且微小的假脚，而这个完整的故事情节被剪掉了。
Oh my gosh. Yeah. That's amazing. Well, that's the episode that Kelly directed. Yes, in season nine. Well, I can't wait to talk to her about this and many more things, and I can't wait for you guys to hear everything she has to share. It's absolutely wonderful.
天哪。是的。太棒了。嗯，那是凯利导演的那一集。是的，在第九季。嗯，我迫不及待地想和她聊聊这件事以及更多的事情，我迫不及待地想让你们听到她要分享的一切。绝对太棒了。
Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we're going to jump right in. Yay, Kelly's here! Hi, Kelly, how are you? I'm awesome. Hi, Anne, hi Jenna. It's so great to see you guys. We are so excited to have you today. You have no idea. We talk about you all the time on the podcast, which you told us people tell you that we talk about you on the podcast. And now we have you here and we get to share you with everyone.
好吧，我们休息一下。等我们回来，马上就切入正题。耶，凯利来了！嗨，凯利，你好吗？我太棒了。嗨，安，嗨，珍娜。很高兴见到你们。我们太高兴你能来了。你根本不知道。我们在播客里经常谈论你，正如你告诉我们的那样，人们会告诉你我们在播客里谈论你。现在你来了，我们可以把你介绍给每个人。
We have lots of questions. So I'm just going to jump right in with question number one, which is we always ask our guests how they came to work on the office. So can you tell us your story? I had just turned into a first AD. So I was doing both. I was doing second AD work and first AD work. And I had made a decision to only be a first AD and not keep working as a second. And then Ross Novi called me. He was doing a pilot called Early Bird with Kent Zabornak producing.
我们有很多问题。所以我直接从第一个问题开始，我们总是问我们的嘉宾他们是怎么加入《办公室》的。所以你能给我们讲讲你的故事吗？我刚刚转为第一副导演。所以我两者都在做。我既做第二副导演的工作，也做第一副导演的工作。我做出了决定，只做第一副导演，不再继续担任第二副导演。然后罗斯·诺维给我打电话。他正在制作一部名为《早起鸟》的试播集，肯·扎博纳克担任制片人。
So Kent Zabornak was the producer on Early Bird and also was the producer, as he described it, of a little comedy called The Office. And I took the job as a second. Ross told everybody I was doing him a favor comedy called The Office. And I took the job as a second. Ross told everybody I was doing him a favor and I was really first. And a few weeks after the pilot, Kent Spornak called me and said,
所以肯·扎博纳克是《早起鸟》的制片人，同时也是他所描述的一部名为《办公室》的小喜剧的制片人。我接受了第二副导演的工作。罗斯告诉所有人我是帮他一个忙喜剧名为《办公室》。我接受了第二副导演的工作。罗斯告诉所有人我是帮他一个忙，而我其实是第一副导演。试播集几周后，肯·斯波纳克给我打电话说，
hey, this little show I'm doing called The Office. It's really funny. It's a group of nice people. Are you available? Can you come meet the showrunner? So I went somewhere in the middle of Burbank to a very strange, I think it was a post-production house because Greg was working on season one. I went and found Kent and we sat in a
嘿，我正在制作的这个小节目叫《办公室》。它真的很有趣。这是一群很好的人。你有空吗？你能来见见剧集运作人吗？所以我去了伯班克中间某个地方的一个非常奇怪的，我想是一个后期制作公司的地方，因为格雷格在制作第一季。我去了，找到了肯，我们坐在一间
small room and Greg Daniels came in and asked me a bunch of questions about what I did in my free time in my real life. We talked about sailing and we talked about hiking. Then he looked over his shoulder and walked out after about five, six minutes. He's dead silent. I look at Kent and I said, do you think he's coming back? Kent said, unknown, let's wait 10 minutes. After 10 minutes, Greg didn't come back.
小房间里，格雷格·丹尼尔斯进来问了我一堆关于我在空闲时间、在现实生活中做什么的问题。我们聊了帆船，我们聊了远足。然后他看了看他的肩膀，大约五六分钟后就走出去了。他死一般地安静。我看着肯说，你觉得他会回来吗？肯说，不知道，等10分钟吧。10分钟后，格雷格没有回来。
And Kent said, well, I guess the interview's over. I'll give you a call. I was like, all right, great. And he called me the next day and said we'd like you to start on season two. You must have some great sailing and hiking stories. It's like so random. What did you think when you got the job? Were you like, what have I gotten myself into?
肯说，好吧，我想面试结束了。我会给你打电话的。我说，好吧，太棒了。他第二天打电话给我说，我们希望你从第二季开始。你一定有一些关于帆船和远足的好故事。这太随机了。你得到这份工作时是怎么想的？你有没有想过，我到底卷入了一个什么地方？
So I hadn't done a lot of comedy. I had done a couple of comedy things. The pilot was a comedy and the pilot that I did, we worked less than 12 hours. Everybody was happy. It was funny. And I thought, yes, I'd like to do a comedy, more of this. And I hadn't seen any of season one, the first six episodes when I did the interview. Fortunately, we didn't talk about season one or television. And then I got the DVD and I watched all the episodes. Kimber if I got the DVD or if they reared or something on NBC. And I watched all the episodes and at the end of it, I thought, huh, well, the people are nice. It's 28 minutes from my house. We're going to be 12 episodes and then I'll be looking for work again. It wasn't your cup of tea. No, I was just like, huh.
所以我以前没做过很多喜剧。我做过几件喜剧的事情。试播集是一部喜剧，我做的那个试播集，我们工作了不到12小时。每个人都很高兴。这很有趣。我想，是的，我想拍一部喜剧，更多这样的作品。而且我在面试时没有看过第一季的任何内容，前六集都没有看。幸运的是，我们没有谈论第一季或电视。然后我得到了DVD，我看了所有的集数。金伯，如果我得到了DVD或者它们在NBC重播什么的。我看了所有的集数，在看完之后，我想，呃，好吧，人很好。离我家28分钟。我们要拍12集，然后我又得找工作了。这不是你的菜。不，我只是觉得，呃。
And then somewhere like four or five episodes into season two, it was so funny. I was like, this is the funniest thing I've ever seen. Ah. You know, for our listeners who maybe aren't familiar with exactly what a first AD does for a production. Could you give us a little brief description of your job? So I used to describe my job as a crest between a cocktail waitress and a fourth grade teacher. You have time to go to the bathroom, you pick your toys up and get ready to go to lunch.
然后在第二季拍到第四集或第五集左右时，它太搞笑了。我想，这是我见过的最好笑的东西。啊。你知道，对于那些可能不熟悉第一副导演在制作中具体做什么的听众来说。你能对你的工作做一个简短的描述吗？所以我以前把我的工作描述为鸡尾酒女服务员和四年级老师的结合体。你有时间去洗手间，你把玩具捡起来准备去吃午饭。
But now the more grown up way to describe it is a project manager. But now the more grown-up way to describe it is Project Manager. So I take the script, which is like the blueprint, and I do all the prep to make it so that we can shoot what's on the page. And then when we shoot, I run the floor on my camera. Kelly, did you ever get a script and think, how are we going to do this? Yes. A couple of them. One of them was the fire drill called open.
但现在，更成熟的描述方式是一个项目经理。但现在，更成熟的描述方式是项目经理。所以我拿着剧本，这就像蓝图，我做所有的前期准备，以便我们能拍摄纸上写的内容。然后当我们拍摄时，我在我的镜头前管理现场。凯利，你有没有拿到剧本时想，我们要怎么拍这个？是的。有几个。其中一个是名为火灾演习的开场。
Mm-hmm. Uh-huh. What part of it? There were so many crazy things, which was the one that stumped you. Like all of it, okay, so all of it was a little crazy but doable. There's lots of chaos and running around and smoke and we had to figure out how to lock the doors but not violate fire codes so that if something happened you guys could actually get off the set. And then the cat. Oh Lord, the cat. So at some point in the prep week, standing on stage, it was Jeff Glitz who was the director,
嗯嗯。哦，是的。哪一部分？有那么多疯狂的事情，哪一个把你难住了？就像所有的，好吧，所以所有的都有点疯狂但可行。有很多混乱、到处跑、烟雾，我们必须弄清楚如何锁上门但不违反消防规范，以便如果发生什么事，你们真的能离开片场。然后是猫。哦天哪，猫。所以在前期准备周的某个时候，站在舞台上，那是杰夫·格利茨，他是导演，
Greg Daniels, the cat wrangler. Me, I was there to meet the cat that I was going to work with. To meet the cat and also see what, oh, and your stunt double. What you can physically do, right? Yeah, yeah. I have to admit in prep periods when we were trying to work stuff out, I often would fill in for you in trying to figure out how a source person could do it. Angela, just share a story about that Kelly. Not only would you fill in for me because we're a similar height,
格雷格·丹尼尔斯，驯猫师。我，我在那里是为了见我要合作的猫。去见猫，还有看看什么，哦，还有你的特技替身。你能做哪些体力活，对吧？对，对。我必须承认，在前期准备阶段，当我们试图解决问题时，我经常会替你出场，试图弄清楚一个替身演员该怎么做。安吉拉，分享一下凯利的一个故事吧。你不仅会因为我们身高相近而代替我，
I found in my digital clutter photos of our feet, because you were my foot double for a possible storyline, for customer loyalty, which you directed, which is coming up. Yes. I have photos of your feet, Kelly, and my digital cover. I love that. Wait, wait, here, look, look, I think I have them. I think I have it pulled up.
我在我的数码杂物箱里找到了我们的脚的照片，因为你是一个潜在故事情节的脚部替身，为了《客户忠诚度》，那一集是你导演的，马上就要播出了。是的。我有你的脚的照片，凯利，在我的数码收藏里。我喜欢这样。等等，等等，看，看，我想我有。我想我把它调出来了。
Look, there's your feet. Oh my God. Okay, that was the longest also departmental discussion of ever, your feet. I know, I know. We can save it for customer loyalty, but that was so crazy. Okay, okay, back to the cat meeting. So we're all on stage talking about how the scripted thing.
看，那是你的脚。哦，天哪。好吧，那也是史上历时最长的部门讨论，关于你们的脚。我知道，我知道。我们可以把它留到《客户忠诚度》那集，但那太疯狂了。好吧，好吧，回到见猫环节。所以我们都在舞台上讨论剧本里的事情。
The Wrangler had said to me, Angela says, save Bandit, throws the cat up in the ceiling, and then Oscar is in a panic to get out and save his life. So we talk about using a stuffed cat, like a stuffy double of the cat. We talk about an animatronic cat, but if we kick in animatronic cat, it's thousands of dollars of smashed machinery, and they think that we brought a stuffy, and the stuffy looked like a stuffy going through the air and there's lots of Conversation so then the Wrangler and I pitched I occasionally pitched things that were either safer or funnier and usually Got shot down
驯猫师对我说，安吉拉说，救救班迪特，把猫往天花板上一扔，然后奥斯卡惊慌失措地逃跑以保全性命。所以我们讨论使用一只毛绒猫，比如猫的毛绒替身。我们讨论了一只电子猫，但如果我们踢一只电子猫，那就是价值数千美元的粉碎机械，他们认为我们带了一只毛绒玩具，而毛绒玩具在空中飞过时看起来就像一个毛绒玩具，而且有很多讨论。所以驯猫师和我提出了一个建议，我偶尔会提出一些更安全或更搞笑的建议，通常都被否决了。
But we pitched could we throw the cat up through the ceiling and just have it fall through a different part of the ceiling and then we had to do a big discussion of part of the ceiling. And then we had to do a big discussion of explanation to everyone about how that was okay because it would be a second cat falling onto a fall pad and that wouldn't permanently scar or hurt the cat. But it was a two hour discussion. And I just imagine you coming home from a day of work. I'm like, how was your day, babe? Would you, would you, well, I figured out how to get a cat out of a ceiling safely. How was your day? I had lots of days like that. What's another one? The other one, which may surprise you guys, Prince Family Paper.
但我们提出了，我们能不能把猫往天花板上扔，然后让它从天花板的不同部分掉下来，然后我们必须进行一场大讨论，关于天花板的一部分。然后我们必须向所有人进行长时间的解释，说明这没关系，因为这将是第二只猫掉落到一个缓冲垫上，那不会永远留下疤痕或伤害这只猫。但这是一个长达两小时的讨论。我只能想象你结束了一天的工作回到家。我说，今天过得怎么样，宝贝？你，你，嗯，我弄清楚了如何安全地把猫从天花板上弄下来。你今天过得怎么样？我有很多那样的日子。还有什么？另一个可能让你们惊讶，普林斯家族纸业。
Prince Family Paper? Why? Yeah. There's no big stunts in that, right? Right. Doesn't appear complicated except Oh, so one of the things we would do almost every episode particularly in the early seasons and Definitely when we had a new director is we'd have a conversation about Documentary camera awareness like so the the regular cast we assumed that the documentary crew had been there for long enough they were used to it. And then people who would come into the office or when we would go out in the street we have to have a conversation about what's the awareness of the camera. Do we assume a producer ran in and said hey documentary cameras coming in don't look at it. Or should people be like hey there's a, Kelly, you're the first person, this whole time that we've been doing the podcast,
普林斯家族纸业？为什么？是的。那里面没有什么大特技，对吧？对。看起来并不复杂，除了哦，所以我们几乎每一集都会做的事情之一，特别是在前几季，绝对是在我们有新导演的时候，我们会谈论纪录片摄像机意识，比如常规演员，我们假设纪录片摄制组在那里待的时间够久，他们已经习惯了。然后是那些来到办公室的人，或者当我们走到街上时，我们必须讨论摄像机的意识。我们是否假设制片人跑进来大喊，嘿，纪录片摄像机要进来了，别看它。或者人们应该表现得像，嘿，有一段，凯利，在我们做播客的整个过程中，你是第一个分享说那是你们每周都会进行的对话的人。我没有意识到这一点，但这完全说得通。如果他们不是这部纪录片的一部分，他们看到摄像机摄制组并做出反应。并提醒新导演，嘿，别忘了，只有这群人，只有邓德米夫林的员工，才对摄像机有这种意识和适应度。如果我们离开这个房间，你必须考虑到这一点。太棒了。这太迷人了。
that has shared that that was a conversation that you guys had every week. I didn't realize that, but it makes perfect sense. If they're not part of this documentary film, that they would see camera crew and react to it. And to remind new directors, hey, don't forget, only this group of people, only the Dunder Mifflin people, have this awareness and comfort with the camera. Like if we leave this room, you have to think about this. Amazing. That's fascinating.
太棒了。这太迷人了。
Along those lines, we also used to, any time there was a sort of a private feeling scene, there'd be a discussion of camera awareness with you guys. Mm-hmm, yeah. I remember those. Which is how we ended up with the spy shot. Like cameras hiding behind a bush, and you might not be aware of it,
顺着这个思路，我们过去也常常，每当有那种私人感觉的场景时，就会和你们讨论摄像机意识。嗯，是的。我记得那些。这就是我们如何得到偷拍镜头的原因。就像藏在灌木丛后面的摄像机，你可能没有意识到，
or it's far enough away from the room that you might not be aware of it. Mm-hmm. So with Prince Family Paper, you had this whole little company that wasn't camera aware? Well, that we're being spied on. Oh, right. Yes, yes. So the guys went to spy on Prince Family Paper so the docker couldn't wait.
或者它离房间足够远，你可能没有意识到。嗯。所以在拍《普林斯家族纸业》时，你们有这么一个根本没有摄像机意识的小公司？嗯，我们是在被监视。哦，对。是的，是的。所以家伙们去监视普林斯家族纸业，这样纪录片组就不能等。
Right. So the parameters for the location, I still remember this because I still drive by empty car dealerships and go, Prince Family Paper, that would have been perfect. So the parameters were, we needed to shoot from outside. So we need glass. All glass. And what we started out looking for was building that was two or three glass walls. What we ended up with was a storefront with one big glass window. So we get there, we go to scout it and it's a mirror.
对。所以外景地的参数，我仍然记得这个，因为我至今开车经过空置的汽车经销商时还会想，普林斯家族纸业，那会是完美的。所以参数是，我们需要从外面拍摄。所以我们需要玻璃。全都是玻璃。我们一开始寻找的是有两面或三面玻璃墙的建筑。我们最终得到的是一个有一面大玻璃窗的店面。所以我们到了那里，我们去堪景，结果是一面镜子。
You know, anytime you go to the grocery store and look in the window, it's a mirror. So then we have to come, we have to rig big black drapes so that there's no reflection and then you're just seeing through the window. The other challenge was because it was a storefront and didn't have a corner, we couldn't do our normal cross covering.
你知道，任何时候你去杂货店看窗户，那都是一面镜子。所以然后我们必须来，我们必须搭建巨大的黑色窗帘，这样就没有反光，然后你就能透过窗户看进去。另一个挑战是，因为它是一个店面而且没有拐角，我们无法进行常规的交叉覆盖。
So we had to shoot everything in one plane from outside the window. And it was super challenging to plan and block and make it look like our show. That episode looks amazing. Now thinking of everything that went into it. Incredible. I love all of that detail. That's so interesting. Mm hmm. So you started working, you said on season two and we noticed, okay, so your first
所以我们必须在窗外的同一个平面上拍摄所有东西。这对于规划、分镜头以及让它看起来像我们的节目来说具有超级大的挑战。那一集看起来棒极了。现在想想里面包含的一切。不可思议。我喜欢所有的细节。这太有趣了。嗯嗯。所以你开始工作，你说是从第二季开始的，我们注意到，好吧，所以你的第一
episode was office Olympics, but you were also the AD for booze crews. And we definitely shared a lot about that episode as a cast. What was it like to prep an episode that we were on a boat? I mean, our show never traveled. Like we were rarely out of the office. We were, had to stay in hotels. The crew stayed in the hotels too. We were down in Long Beach.
集是办公室奥运会，但你也是《酒水游轮》的副导演。作为演员，我们绝对分享了很多关于那一集的感受。在一艘船上拍一集前期准备是什么感觉？我的意思是，我们的节目从来不出外景。就像我们很少离开办公室。我们，不得不住在酒店里。剧组也住在酒店里。我们在长滩。
Yep. So we rented a boat, the party boat, and then Ken Coates and I went through all the scenes and the shots and we figured out what scenes we needed to be out at sea for and what scenes we had to be at the dock for and then what scenes that we were in the script out at sea but could shoot at the dock. So we went through all that, and then the marine coordinator Ransom and Mike George, we go through all the boat stuff we need with them, and they organize the water stuff. And then we start organizing the locate.
是的。所以我们租了一艘船，派对船，然后肯·科茨和我仔细检查了所有的场景和镜头，我们弄清楚了哪些场景我们需要出海拍，哪些场景我们需要在码头拍，以及剧本中哪些场景是在海上但可以在码头拍的。所以我们经历这一切，然后海洋协调员兰瑟姆和迈克·乔治，我们和他们一起过一遍所有关于船的事情，他们组织水上的事。然后我们开始组织外景。
We could shoot this scene because it's down below, and we don't see everywhere. We'll shoot this at the dock like we're out at sea. Well, we need to pretend we're moving. So then lighting organizes a lighting barge where we have lights on a barge that would just go putt, putt, putt, putt, putt, like the shore was moving. So wait, we had a whole barge of lights
我们可以拍这个场景，因为它在下层，而且我们看不到所有地方。我们在码头拍这个，就好像我们在公海一样。嗯，我们需要假装我们在移动。所以照明部门组织了一个照明驳船，我们在驳船上有灯光，就会发出突突突的声音，就像海岸在移动。等等，我们有一整船的灯光
that would go back and forth past the boat? Yeah. I never knew that, Jenna, did you know that? I did not know that was happening, no. When you watch it and there's a scene like on the first floor of the boat, when we're not up on the top deck, and you can see the boat's moving
会来回从船边开过吗？是的。我从来不知道，珍娜，你知道吗？我不知道发生了什么，没有。当你看着它，有这样一个场景，比如在船的一楼，当我们不在顶层甲板上时，你能看到船在移动
and you can see the shore lights moving, that's lights on a barge, cause we were parked. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Kelly, you've got all the nuggets, Kelly. I didn't rewatch Booze Cruise, but I had to think about it. Well, I mean, one of the struggles for the cast on the boat was people really started to get nauseous. And I imagine that was happening with the crew too.
而且你能看到岸上的灯光在移动，那是驳船上的灯光，因为我们停着。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。凯利，你掌握了所有的干货，凯利。我没有重看《酒水游轮》，但我不得不考虑它。嗯，我的意思是，演员在船上的挣扎之一是人们真的开始感到恶心。我想剧组也发生了这种情况。
I think the crew was less sick than the cast. So on the last day, we went out to sea because we had shots that we were supposed to be in the middle of the water and as we're out there and we're rocking and You know particularly you guys actors are not like you can't focus on the horizon or you know push an equipment or you You're acting so it's crazy and then once one person throws up everybody goes so at a certain point the cast actually started heaving over the side. Yeah. And cameras instructed by our showrunner started to go to shoot that. And I remember this. I remember Greg said, get the people vomiting. It's great doc footage. Who was vomiting over the side? Rain a lot. Oh gosh. Rain a lot. And there were a couple other people too, but I argued hard that it wasn't fair.
我觉得剧组比演员没那么难受。所以在最后一天，我们出海了，因为我们有镜头要求我们在水中央，当我们出海时，船在摇晃，你知道，特别是你们演员不像，你们不能专注于地平线，或者你知道，推设备或者你们在演戏，所以这太疯狂了，一旦一个人呕吐，所有人都会跟着吐。所以到了一定程度，演员们实际上开始在船舷边呕吐。是的。在我们的剧集运作人的指示下，摄像机开始去拍摄那个画面。我记得这个。我记得格雷格说，拍下呕吐的人。这是很棒的纪录片素材。是谁在船舷边呕吐？雷恩很多。哦天哪。雷恩很多。还有其他几个人，但我极力争辩说这不公平。
I was like, you can't shoot them really throwing up. It's sort of a vulnerable moment. We shouldn't do that. And I ended up kind of standing in front of the camera while I was making that argument. And then everybody calmed down and I suggested that we could, you know, give people a sip of Coke or something and do fake puking. Wait, wait, you're the reason. Okay.
我说，你们不能真的拍他们呕吐。这有点像个脆弱的时刻。我们不应该这样做。我在提出这个争论时，最终有点站在了摄像机前面。然后大家都冷静下来了，我建议我们可以，你知道，给人们喝一小口可乐什么的，然后假装呕吐。等等，等等，你是罪魁祸首。好吧。
I wondered this cause it was not in the script. Greg came up to me and Kate Flannery and was like, Hey, hey, where you guys are going to puke over the side. We're like, what? And we had a choice of minestrone soup or mushroom soup. And I chose minestrone and you took a swig of it and held it in your mouth. And then anyway, it was disgusting. Even faking it was so gross.
我一直在想这个，因为剧本里没有。格雷格走到我和凯特·弗兰纳里面前说，嘿，嘿，你们两个要在船舷边吐。我们说，什么？我们有蔬菜汤或蘑菇汤可以选择。我选择了蔬菜汤，你喝了一大口，含在嘴里。然后无论如何，这太恶心了。即使是假的也太 gross 了。
Well, I think you and Kate got chosen to fake vomit because you were not real vomiting. We didn't ask anybody who was queasy to fake vomit. I remember because I was on the edge. I did not throw up, but I could have it any moment. And I remember I was like, I can't, I can't fake it. It's going to come out. It's just going to all come out. I mean, holding that cold soup in your mouth was disgusting
嗯，我想你和凯特被选中假装呕吐是因为你们没有真的呕吐。我们没有要求任何感到恶心的人去假装呕吐。我记得因为我在边缘。我没有吐，但我随时都可能吐。我记得我当时想，我不能，我不能假装。它会出来的。它全都会出来的。我的意思是，嘴里含着那碗冷汤太恶心了
because you had to hold it. And then for a few seconds, then they yelled action. Kelly, you're the reason. I'm sorry. I'm going to tell Cape Flannery remember when we had to swig that cold soup. But you were trying to protect the other cast. That's very sweet. So Kelly, you worked on 72 episodes of The Office. How did your job change over the years? Oh, that's a good question. It didn't change much.
因为你必须含着。然后持续了几秒钟，接着他们喊开始。凯利，都是因为你。我很抱歉。我要告诉凯特·弗兰纳里，还记得我们不得不大口吞下那个冷汤的时候吗。但你是在试图保护其他演员。这太甜了。所以凯利，你参与了《办公室》72集的制作。这些年来你的工作是如何变化的？哦，这是个好问题。变化不大。
The stuff that changed was we get new cast. So Daryl moves up from the warehouse and now he's got a desk. Oh, my desk used to be where Daryl's office went. So I lost my desk when I was working. Yes, you used to be in the corner over there. Yes. But I think the job stayed the same. Oh, I will say when we started,
变化的是我们有了新演员。所以达里尔从仓库升职了，现在他有了一张办公桌。哦，我的办公桌以前是达里尔的办公室所在的地方。所以我工作时失去了办公桌。是的，你以前就在那边那个角落。是的。但我认为工作保持不变。哦，我要说的是，当我们刚开始的时候，
nobody was famous. There were no requests for your cast to be on talk shows in the beginning. Right. We didn't have to work around like someone like doing a movie or a press junket. We were always, always available. Right. So nobody was a movie star. It wasn't like, oh, I need to go do the Tonight Show. And so it was pretty easy to schedule cast. And scheduling with cast just became a little bit more challenging as everybody got famous and had other stuff to do. Yeah.
没有人出名。一开始没有人要求你们的演员去脱口秀节目。对。我们不必围绕某人拍电影或参加新闻发布会来安排工作。我们总是，随时都有空。对。所以没有人是电影明星。这不像是，哦，我需要去上今夜秀。所以安排演员档期相当容易。随着每个人都成名并有了其他事情要做，与演员的档期协调变得更有挑战性了。是的。
I have to thank you, Kelly, just from the bottom of my heart. And Jenna knows this too, and it's something we've talked a lot about, which is I was the first cast member, not crew or, you know, but just the first cast member that had a baby. The fellas had kids, but I was pregnant on set, and then I had to breastfeed. And all of the things that went into going back to work as a working mom with a newborn and you just stepped up for me in such a huge way. I was having to figure out how to go to my trailer and pump and you were giving me breaks in scenes.
我必须感谢你，凯利，发自内心地感谢你。珍娜也知道这一点，这是我们讨论过很多次的事情，那就是我是第一个怀孕的演员，不是剧组人员，或者你知道的，只是第一个怀孕的演员。小伙子们有孩子，但我是在片场怀孕的，然后我不得不母乳喂养。所有作为一个带着新生儿的职业母亲重返工作岗位所经历的事情，你以如此巨大的方式支持了我。我不得不弄清楚如何去我的拖车里吸奶，而你在场景中给我休息时间。
You were scheduling when I could go take care of myself and my baby and then you did the same for Jenna and it means so much to us. And we just love you so much for, for just taking care of us during that time. I remember sitting down with each of you and saying, I have never had a baby. What do you need? Yes. I'm like, well, I'm going to need to pump and also I might need some snacks after I pump. Right.
你当时在安排我什么时候可以去照顾自己和我的宝宝，然后你又为珍娜做了同样的事情，这让我们感动不已。我们真的非常爱你，在那个时候照顾我们。我记得和你们每个人坐在一起，然后说，我从来没生过孩子。你们需要什么？是的。我说，嗯，我需要吸奶，而且吸完奶后我可能还需要一些零食。没错。
Yeah. I shared Kelly this really amazing thing that you did, which was, I don't know if you remember, but you came up to me and you said, Jenna, the law in California is that I must allow you to leave set to pump your breast milk. The law is not that I have to allow you to leave set to nurse your baby. So if you just let me know when you need to pump your breast milk, I won't ask where exactly it's going. I like started crying. I was like, I got it. Got it. Scheduling you guys was often more interesting than scheduling the show.
对。我跟凯利分享了你做的这件非常了不起的事，我不确定你是否还记得，但你走到我面前对我说，珍娜，加利福尼亚州的法律规定我必须允许你离开片场去吸母乳。法律并没有规定我必须允许你离开片场去喂养你的宝宝。所以你只要告诉我什么时候需要吸母乳就行，我不会追问这奶到底是用来干嘛的。我当时感动得哭了起来。我说，我明白了。明白了。给你们排班往往比安排节目本身更有趣。
But to that point. Okay, Jenna, one other thing, and this is your fault. My skill set is an AD got better because of you oh You produced a low-budget movie one summer and the next season as a first or second day I was on set doing something and you came in and I think you were talking to Angela about producing this movie and All the stuff you had to do and you were had to dig through trash and clean toilets and stuff you had to do and you had to dig through trash and clean toilets and all the stuff a producer normally does on a low budget movie because there's no one else. So, Pajena, it's kind of interesting to hear your perspective of producing.
但说到这一点。好吧，珍娜，还有一件事，这得怪你。我的助理导演技能因为你而变得更好了。哦，有一年夏天你制作了一部低成本电影，到了下一季，当我作为第一或第二助理导演在片场做事情时，你走过来，我想你当时在和安吉拉谈论制作这部电影的事，以及你所有必须做的事情，你不得不翻找垃圾、清理厕所等等，这些都是制片人在低成本电影中通常要做的事情，因为没有别人。所以，帕珍娜，听到你对制片工作的看法挺有意思的。
And you said to me, you know, I was really thinking about it of how come when I'm producing, I walk into a location and the bathroom's filthy and I think, oh my god, the actors are coming, I should clean this. And you told me that what you had decided was when you are a producer, you are in charge. And so it's your job to make things right for other people. But when you're an actor, you are not in charge of anything. That the AD is the one who tells you when to come to work, when to go to makeup, when you can go to the bathroom, when you have time to eat, when you can go home. And that if another person had that much control over your daily life, it better be perfect.
你对我说，你知道的，我一直在思考，为什么当我担任制片人时，我走进一个地方，发现洗手间很脏，然后我会想，天哪，演员们要来了，我应该把这里打扫干净。而你告诉我，你的决定是，当你是一名制片人时，你是负责人。所以你的工作就是为其他人把事情做好。但当你是一名演员时，你对任何事情都不负责。助理导演才是那个告诉你什么时候来上班、什么时候去化妆、什么时候可以去上厕所、什么时候有时间吃饭、什么时候可以回家的人。如果另一个人对你的日常生活拥有这么大的控制权，那一切最好都完美无缺。
And I thought, oh my gosh, that makes so much sense. That is a totally valid point of view. And I need to actually internalize that and use it in the rest of my life. You know, it was really eye-opening for me to produce because I worked so hard as that indie producer and I was happy to be a servant to the needs of everybody on the set. You know, if someone else needed to sit down, I would give up my seat. You know, it was just like, it is literally my job to make this day run as smoothly as possible, however big or small those things are that I do all day. It was really eyeopening to me how in my point of view, how little autonomy an actor has over their day. As an actor, as Pam, if I was like, oh,
然后我想，哦天哪，这太有道理了。这完全是一个正确的观点。我实际上需要把它内化，并在我余下的生活中运用它。你知道的，制作对我来说真的大开眼界，因为作为那个独立制片人，我工作得非常努力，而且我很高兴能成为片场所有人需求的公仆。你知道，如果其他人需要坐下，我会把我的座位让出来。你知道，这就像，让这一天尽可能顺利地进行，无论我一整天做的那些事情有多大或多小，这字面意思上就是我的工作。从我的角度来看，演员对他们的一天有多少自主权，这让我大开眼界。作为一名演员，作为帕姆，如果我说，哦，
you know what, I would really love some coffee, your instinct is to get up and get yourself some coffee. But if I were to get up and move from my place, like you or a PA would be like, my God, where are you going? Where are you? Why are you stepping away? Don't leave. Don't leave. Don't go anywhere. And I'd be like, well, I want some coffee. They'll be like, we'll get you the coffee. We'll get you to just sit back down. Just go ahead and have a seat, have a seat, sit down, what do you want in your coffee?
你知道吗，我真的很想喝杯咖啡，你的本能是站起来给自己弄杯咖啡。但如果我从我的位置站起来走开，像你或制片助理就会说，天哪，你要去哪里？你在哪？你为什么走开？别走。别走。哪儿也别去。然后我会说，嗯，我想喝咖啡。他们会说，我们会给你弄咖啡的。我们会让你坐回原位。快坐下，快坐下，坐下，你想在咖啡里加什么？
How do you want your coffee? And so as an actor, you become almost trained to do nothing except act, except be ready to act at any time. Because, you know, I couldn't walk into a restroom and be like, this is dirty, I'm gonna clean it for the next person because the wardrobe and everything would be like, oh my God, what are you doing?
你想要什么样的咖啡？因此，作为一名演员，你几乎被训练得除了演戏之外什么也不做，除了随时准备演戏之外什么也不做。因为，你知道的，我不能走进洗手间说，这里很脏，我要为下一个人把它打扫干净，因为服装部门和其他所有人都会说，天哪，你在干什么？
Why are you, you're gonna potentially mess up, go sit down, sit in this chair and don't move. Someone else will clean that toilet. It's so weird, the difference between being an actor and then being part of the other side of the camera. Hopefully we take all the stuff that gets in the way of acting out of your peripheral so you can just pay attention to the acting. You did. You definitely did that. You totally did.
为什么你要，你可能会把事情搞砸，快坐下，坐在椅子上别动。别人会去打扫那个马桶的。太奇怪了，当演员和成为镜头另一边的人之间的区别。希望我们能把所有妨碍演戏的东西从你的视线边缘清除出去，这样你就可以专心演戏了。你做到了。你绝对做到了。你真的做到了。
You definitely did that. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we have some more questions for you. Kelly, for example, we have not yet talked about your famous safety meetings, and we will need to do that. Okay. We are back with Kelly and Kelly. We really need a safety meeting. No one does it better than you. Can you please do a safety meeting for us?
你绝对做到了。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下？当我们回来时，我们还有更多问题要问你。比如凯利，我们还没聊过你著名的安全会议，我们需要聊聊这个。好的。我们和凯利以及凯利回来了。我们真的很需要一次安全会议。没有人比你做得更好。你能为我们开个安全会议吗？
I'll give you one. It is garage sale. The cast is all standing in a line in the kitchen holding lit candles. Michael and Holly are about to enter. Could you give us a safety meeting, please? Okay, but wait, before I tell you the safety meeting, I should tell you what happened in the prep. Oh! In the prep for that scene, we figured out whether or not
我给你们开一个。这是车库大卖场那一集。演员们都排成一排站在厨房里，手里拿着点燃的蜡烛。迈克尔和霍莉正要进来。你能给我们开个安全会议吗？好吧，但是等等，在我告诉你安全会议之前，我应该告诉你准备工作时发生了什么。哦！为了那个场景的准备工作，我们弄清楚了是否
we needed a fire marshal on set for that. I can't remember if we needed one or not, but we needed special effects with fire extinguishers. We also made sure that the whole hair department knew not to use hairspray because it's flammable. And costumes didn't dress anyone in polyester because it's also flammable. Wow. So this all happened before the safety meeting. So then the safety meeting, because I'm not an actor. Well, but I was in one episode. But from your point of view, you're in the scene, you're in the
我们需要在片场安排一个消防员。我不记得当时需不需要了，但我们需要带有灭火器的特效。我们还确保整个发型部门知道不要使用发胶，因为它是易燃的。服装部门也没有给任何人穿涤纶衣服，因为它也是易燃的。哇。所以这一切都发生在安全会议之前。然后是安全会议，因为我不是演员。好吧，但我客串过一集。但从你的角度来看，你在场景中，你在
moment, you're playing whatever the real-life thing is. So I'd have to say, okay, everybody's holding a candle, it's actual flame. Pay attention, don't burn anyone, don't bend your head over the candle and set your hair on fire, and then John would make fun of me. You know, now that I know your sort of lens of your job description of a cocktail waitress and a fourth grade teacher, your safety meetings are now so much more colorful to me because that is exactly what it would sound like. You'd be like, this is an open flame. It is a real fire.
当下，你在扮演任何现实生活中的事情。所以我不得不说，好吧，每个人都拿着蜡烛，这是真正的火焰。注意，不要烧到任何人，不要把头凑到蜡烛上把头发点着了，然后约翰就会取笑我。你知道的，现在我了解了你作为鸡尾酒女服务员和四年级老师的工作职责的视角，你的安全会议对我来说要丰富多彩得多，因为听起来确实就是那样。你会说，这是一明火。这是真正的火。
Do not put your face over it. Do not put your friend's face over it. Keep your hands to yourself. Exactly. What about your reminder meetings? We have not talked about that, but they were equally delicious. On almost every shot, because everyone had live internet and also people get thirsty and we're limited in what brands we can show, I would say, okay, pictures up.
不要把脸凑上去。不要把朋友的脸凑上去。管好你自己的手。没错。你的提醒会议呢？我们还没聊过那个，但它们同样精彩。在几乎每一个镜头中，因为每个人都有实时互联网，而且人们也会口渴，我们在能展示的品牌上受到限制，我会说，好吧，准备拍摄。
Water bottles, sides, Diet Cokes, them, and make sure your screens on something we're allowed to see. That was it, yeah. Make sure your screen is on something we're allowed to see. And sometimes she would call someone out. Sometimes we're like, rain? Yeah, so I would call Rowling, and I'd wait to point at the director to say go until all the screens had flipped and particularly during fantasy football season
水瓶、台词、健怡可乐，把这些收好，并确保你们屏幕上的内容是我们允许看到的。就是这样，对。确保你们的屏幕显示的是我们允许看到的内容。有时她会点名。有时我们会说，瑞恩？对，所以我点瑞恩的名字，我会等着指着导演说开始，直到所有屏幕都翻过去，特别是美式橄榄球赛季期间
Sometimes rain if he wasn't talking would be involved in this computer and not flip it And so I'd say rain your computer or whoever was mostly rain but it was also other people sometimes and one day rain said to me Kelly I Always have my computer on something we're allowed to see. You never need to remind me again. I remember this. I said, okay, what do I get if you miss it? I will give $100 to the charity of your choice. Okay. And then, I think it was a couple months later, he messed it up and I said okay, rain
有时瑞恩如果不说话，就会盯着这台电脑看而不把它翻过去。所以我会说，瑞恩，管管你的电脑，或者是其他任何人，虽然主要是瑞恩，但有时也是其他人。有一天瑞恩对我说，凯利，我的电脑屏幕上显示的总是我们允许看到的内容。你再也不需要提醒我了。我记得这个。我说，好吧，如果你错过了，我能得到什么？我将向你选择的慈善机构捐赠100美元。好吧。然后，我想是几个月后，他弄砸了，我说好吧，瑞恩
a hundred bucks to Meals on Wheels. It's like what? It's like your screen. Okay, and I think over the years It was about three thousand dollars To Meals on Wheels? Yeah, and right it was season eight or season nine it happened again and I said okay a hundred bucks to Meals on Wheels. And Rain said, that's not fair. I didn't even know I was on camera. And he goes on this whole rant about it's not fair.
给“送餐上门”慈善机构捐一百块钱。就像什么？就像你的屏幕。好吧，我想多年来，这大约是三千美元，捐给了“送餐上门”慈善机构？是的，而且对，那是第八季或第九季，这事又发生了，我说好吧，给“送餐上门”慈善机构捐一百块钱。瑞恩说，这不公平。我甚至不知道我在镜头里。然后他开始长篇大论地说这不公平。
It's not fair. I didn't know I was on camera. That was sneaky. And you needed to warn me. And Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but you stood up and said, Oh no, I remember how many seasons ago you told her, You don't need to tell me ever again. That's right. I was like, you gave a whole speech about how she never had to say it again.
这不公平。我不知道我在镜头里。这太偷偷摸摸了。你需要警告我。珍娜，我不知道你是否还记得，但你站起来说，哦不，我记得多少季以前你对她说，你再也不用告诉我了。没错。我就像，你发表了一大演讲，说她再也不用说了。
That you would always have it ready. That's awesome. All right. I have a question for you, Kelly. So, you know, all of us would break in scenes. We were horrible. We would try so hard not to ruin takes, but we would get the giggles. So I have to know, did you ever break?
你总是会准备好的。太棒了。好的。我有个问题要问你，凯利。所以，你知道的，我们所有人都会在拍戏时笑场。我们太糟糕了。我们会竭尽全力不毁掉镜头，但我们会忍不住咯咯笑。所以我必须知道，你笑场过吗？
Was there a moment where you were laughing? All the time. Did you ever ruin a take? I never ruined a take, but I had to actually leave set the episode where Michael Scott gives the short joke one. To me? Miss Muffet? Yes. Yes.
有没有某一刻你在笑？一直都在笑。你毁过镜头吗？我从未毁过镜头，但迈克尔·斯科特讲矮子笑话的那一集，我真的不得不离开片场。对我？玛菲小姐？对。对。
Well, first of all, Steve improvised a few short jokes. So, okay, so I remember at the beat, we were getting ready to shoot the scene and it was there were a couple of like, I forget what the scripted thing was, it was a short joke thing. And right before we went, he turned to you and he said, and I'm going to improv and come up with a bunch. That okay? And you said, you can't come up with one I haven't heard.
好吧，首先，史蒂夫即兴讲了几个矮子笑话。所以，好吧，我记得在那个节拍，我们正准备拍那个场景，有几个，我忘了剧本里原本是什么了，是个矮子笑话的东西。就在我们开拍前，他转过身对你，他说，我要即兴发挥，想出一堆。行吗？然后你说，你绝对想不出一个我没听过的。
Why would I say that to Steve of all people? He said you're on. And then he said like 100 short joke things in the however many takes. It was so funny. Oh my gosh. I don't know why I ever challenged Steve to any kind of like comedy joke. Did you ever get to pitch jokes? Did you ever make suggestions or did you more hang back? I mean, I know you had to make suggestions like how do we practically get this cat in this ceiling
我怎么会对史蒂夫这样的人说那种话？他说，你等着。然后他在随后的无数次拍摄中，大概说了一百个矮子笑话。太搞笑鸟。哦天哪。我不知道为什么我曾经会向史蒂夫发起任何喜剧笑话的挑战。你有机会提出笑话吗？你曾经提出过建议，还是只是在旁边观望？我的意思是，我知道你不得不提出建议，比如我们如何实际地把这只猫弄到天花板里
and also live through it. But what about like creatively? So generally like you don't wanna be the wouldn't it be funny if person? Sure. Right? But occasionally I have an idea for a line or a joke and I would say to Greg, can I pitch? And he'd say, sure, or to the writer. Can I pitch? Sure.
还能活着出来。但是创意方面呢？所以一般来说，你不会想成为那种“这样不是很搞笑吗”的人？当然。对吧？但偶尔我对某句台词或笑话有个想法，我会对格雷格说，我可以提个建议吗？他会说，当然，或者对编剧说。我可以提个建议吗？当然。
And occasionally it would make it in and then when we would shoot I would get on my radio and say to the ideas, I did that. I said that line. Yay. Yay. Okay. This is a big question. How has working on the office affected your career?
有时候它能播出来，然后当我们拍摄时，我会用对讲机对副导演说，我做到了。我说那句台词了。太棒了。太棒了。好的。这是一个大问题。《办公室》的工作对你的职业生涯有什么影响？
Oh, interesting. Okay. I recently had an interview for a feature that didn't end up going. So I don't know if I would have gotten the job. They asked me what my superpower was, and I said scheduling. Yeah. And I learned it on the office. I don't know if you remember, but I used to do my schedule, and then on Friday,
哦，很有趣。好的。我最近为一个最终没成的项目进行了一次试镜。所以我不知道我是否会得到这份工作。他们问我的超能力是什么，我说排程。是的。我是从《办公室》里学会的。我不知道你是否还记得，但我以前会做排程，然后到星期五，
I would print my little one-liner, and I would highlight, like, I think, Jenny, you were always pink. Mm-hmm. And you were, I think you were a blue circle. I can't quite remember. Every actor would have a color around their number on the one line. Yes. And I bring the schedule to set on Friday and I would run every actor through their
我会打印出我小小的单行剧本，我会用荧光笔标记，我想，珍娜，你总是粉红色的。嗯哼。而你，我想你是一个蓝色圆圈。我记不太清了。每个演员在单行剧本上他们的编号周围都会有一种颜色。是的。我把排程带到片场，在星期五我会带每个演员过一遍他们的
schedule for the week. It was so helpful. But also somewhere, argueers. Oh, I think maybe I argued. Am I an arguer, Kelly, or was I in the middle? No, you were a good idea. Oh! Oh! Because of my second life as an AD! I had a lot of bright ideas when I would look at the one liner. Kelly, one time I went up to you because Jenna, I like got the schedule and Jenna was like,
一周排程。这太有帮助了。但不知何故，也有人喜欢争论。哦，我想也许我争论过。我是个爱争论的人吗，凯利，还是我在中间？不，你很有想法。哦！哦！因为我作为副导演的第二人生！当我看着单行剧本时，我有很多好点子。凯利，有一次我走到你面前，因为珍娜，我拿到了排程，珍娜说，
Ange, if they move that one scene up, you would have the whole afternoon. You could go to Isabel's school. You could volunteer. Like she would always have ideas for me. And I went to you and I was like, you know, if this scene were a little earlier, and I am telling you, you were like, were you talking to Jenna? So I would try and make the best schedule for everybody.
安吉，如果他们把那场戏提前，你就会整个下午都有空。你可以去伊莎贝尔的学校。你可以去做义工。她总是能为我想出点子。我走到你面前说，你知道，如果这场戏能早一点，我向你保证，你会说，你在跟珍娜说话吗？所以我总是想为每个人做出最好的排程。
And I also would be really upfront about saying, hey, this Wednesday you're here all day and I'm sorry I can't fix it or this Tuesday you got a big gap in the middle and so I Think coming up with a schedule that was good for everybody made me a really good scheduler. You were fantastic and I also learned to not Be afraid of talking to cast like Jen. I used to come to you and say, okay, you can work three 12 hour days this week, or I can bring in every single day for not the full day,
而且我也会非常坦率地说，嘿，这个星期三你一整天都在这儿，很抱歉我无法更改；或者这个星期二中间有一大段空闲。所以我觉得想出一个对大家都有好处的排程，让我成了一个非常出色的排程员。你太棒了，而且我也学会了不怕和演员说话，比如詹。我以前会来找你，说，好吧，你这周可以工作三天，每天12小时；或者我可以让你每天都来，但不是全天，
which is better for you. And you tell me. And when it really didn't matter to schedule, I could give you a choice. And I always appreciated that. And I always appreciated that. And that was especially true after I had my son. So I became a better scheduler and then also some of the connections I've made. I've worked with
哪种对你更好？你告诉我。当排程其实无所谓时，我可以让你做出选择。我一直很感激这一点。我一直很感激这一点。在我有了儿子之后，这一点尤其明显。所以我成了一个更好的排程员，还有我建立的一些人脉。我合作过
some of the directors and producers from the office continuing. I'm Matt Son and I just did an indie feature. Aw. Amazing. Love it. Oh, and I've kept working with Greg. I did the pilots for Upload and Space Force and then the first season of Space Force. Amazing. Yeah. So, we've obviously talked about a lot of episodes, a lot of behind the scenes stuff, but have we missed anything? Were there any special memories from being on the show or anything you wanted to share? No, I can't think of...no, every day was special in the office.
《办公室》的一些导演和制片人，一直合作至今。我是马特·桑的粉丝，我刚拍了一部独立电影。啊。太棒了。真喜欢。哦，我还一直在和格雷格合作。我拍了《上载新生》和《太空部队》的试播集，还有《太空部队》的第一季。太棒了。是的。所以，我们显然聊了很多集，很多幕后花絮，但我们漏掉了什么吗？在节目中有什么特别的回忆，或者任何你想分享的事吗？不，我想不出……不，在《办公室》里的每一天都很特别。
Oh, I love that. Seriously, it was like, okay, for everybody who listens to you that doesn't work in TV, it's like going to summer camp and going to the same summer camp with the same kids for eight years. Oh, just like that. Do you ever rewatch the show? I did early days, but started rewatching it last night when I was looking at the questions you were gonna ask. And now I wanna go back and start from the beginning.
哦，我太喜欢这样了。说真的，就像是，好吧，对于所有不从事电视行业的听众来说，这就像去夏令营，和同一群孩子连续八年去同一个夏令营。哦，就是那样。你还会重看这部剧吗？早期看过，但昨晚我在看你们要问的问题时，又开始重看了。现在我想回去从头开始看。
I do too. Kelly, it's such a pleasure to rewatch. It is really just, it brings back so many personal memories when I'm watching it. And also there's so many things being so far away from it that I forgot. So jokes surprise me. It's really cool.
我也是。凯利，重看真是太享受了。它真的唤起了我太多的个人回忆。而且离它这么远，有太多事情我都忘了。所以笑话总能给我惊喜。真的很酷。
I watched the search, and I was there. I did a safety meeting on the roof, and I did not remember any of it until I watched it. We have the same experience. All right, we always ask our guests if they took anything from the show when it wrapped. Jenna and I took several things. Kelly, did you take anything? All right, we always ask our guests if they took anything from the show when it wrapped, Jenna and I took several things. Kelly, did you take anything? I did, but it wasn't when it wrapped.
我看了《搜寻》，我当时就在现场。我在屋顶开过安全会议，但在看之前我完全不记得了。我们有同样的经历。好了，我们总是问嘉宾，在剧集杀青时他们有没有从剧组拿走什么东西。珍娜和我拿了几样东西。凯利，你拿了吗？好了，我们总是问嘉宾，在剧集杀青时他们有没有从剧组拿走什么东西，珍娜和我拿了几样东西。凯利，你拿了吗？我拿了，但不是在杀青时。
What was it? Okay, so the episode where Michael's looking for Holly and he goes to the office and she's not there, it's after she's changed branches and her sweater is on the chair. Mm-hmm. And he cuts the sleeve off her sweater. Yes. I ended up with two of those sleeves. Oh, you have Holly's sleeves too.
是什么？好的，就是迈克尔寻找霍莉的那集，他去办公室但她不在，那是她换了分行之后，她的椅子上放着一件毛衣。嗯哼。他剪掉了她毛衣的袖子。是的。我最后得到了那件毛衣的两只袖子。哦，你也拥有霍莉的袖子。
Well, cause we did it like seven times. So I was thinking, cause we were always so cold on that set. And I was thinking, oh, this would be like an arm warmer. And so I ended up with two randomly cause I thought I might use them. Emily packed them away and forgot about them. And then I did a show, I did Space Force, and the production designer, Susie,
嗯，因为我们拍了大约七次。所以我在想，因为我们在那个片场总是觉得很冷。我在想，哦，这就像一个暖袖。所以我莫名其妙地得到了两个，因为我想我可能会用到它们。艾米把它们打包收好，然后就忘了。后来我做了一个节目，我做了《太空部队》，布景设计师苏西，
told me the only reason that she took the job and desperately wanted the job is because of how uplifting and positive the office was in her life. And it was her favorite show and she watched two episodes every night when she go to bed. And so I gave her one of the sleeves. Aw. And then I was on No Activity and Joe, the producer,
告诉我她接下这份工作并极度渴望得到这份工作的原因，是因为《办公室》在她的生活中给予了她极大的鼓舞和正能量。这是她最喜欢的剧，她每天睡觉前都要看两集。所以我把其中一只袖子送给了她。啊。后来我参加了《无为大师》，制片人乔，
he and his fiance were huge, huge office fans. Like he remembered stuff I didn't remember. They watched it so much and he was proposing. And I gave him the sleeve. Oh, so you have these, but now you've given them away to suit high fans. You're paying it forward. Yeah, so I have the Dundee that Felsey gave me,
他和他的未婚妻是《办公室》的超级超级粉丝。比如他记得一些我都不记得的事情。他们看了无数遍，而且他当时正在求婚。我把袖子送给了他。哦，所以你曾拥有这些，但现在你把它们送给了超级粉丝。你在传递这份爱。是的，所以我留着菲尔·谢给我颁发的邓迪奖，
but I wish I had taken, there were two things of Andy Bernard's that I wish I had taken. I went to a sailboat regatta on my little sailboat and my friend who came in third got a little plastic Lido 14 trophy at Nationals and she was like, I don't want this. What am I going to do with this? She goes, here, see if they want it on your set because she was an office fan. Amy. And so I brought it to set deck and I said, I have a random trophy. Do you want it? And they were like, yes.
但我希望我拿走了，安迪·伯纳德有两样东西我希望我拿走了。我有一次开着我的小帆船去参加帆船赛，我的朋友获得了第三名，在全国赛上得到了一个塑料的莉多14小奖杯，她说她不想要这个。我拿这个能干什么？她说，给你，看看你们片场的人要不要，因为她是一个办公室迷。艾米。所以我把它带到了道具组，我说，我有一个随机的奖杯。你们要吗？他们说，要。
And it landed on Annie Bernard's desk. And I've always regretted it. I didn't ask Ed to sign it and give it back to Amy. Oh. But again, Kelly, the things you want, you want to give to other people. You are just such like a pure hearted person. All right. And then in Andy's office,
它最后落在了安迪·伯纳德的桌子上。我一直对此感到后悔。我没有请埃德在上面签名并还给艾米。哦。但话说回来，凯利，你想要的东西，你都想送给别人。你真的是一个内心如此纯洁的人。好的。然后在安迪的办公室里，
this didn't show up until he was the manager. My husband had been invited to sail on the Cornell alumni team at an amateur big boat regatta in Italy, and he really wanted to go. Satdak heard he was going, and we sent two shirts, Cornell shirts, with him, so he would have one. Everybody else on the boat was from Cornell,
这直到他成为经理才出现。我丈夫曾被邀请去意大利参加业余大帆船赛的康奈尔校友队航行，他真的很想去。道具组听说他要去，给我们寄了两件衬衫，康奈尔的衬衫，和他一起去，这样他就会有一件。船上的其他所有人都是康奈尔的，
so they had one to race. And we sent another shirt and Ed's general measurements. So they took a group photo on the dock of the Cornell sailing team and pulled a random guy off the dock, put the shirt on him, and then we photoshopped Andy's face. Oh my gosh, so your husband's in a picture in Andy's office? My husband and the whole five, six years ago Cornell Alumni Sailing Team.
所以他们有一件可以用来比赛。我们又寄了另一件衬衫和埃德的大致尺寸。于是他们在码头上拍了一张康奈尔帆船队的集体照，随手从码头上拉了一个人，把衬衫套在他身上，然后我们把安迪的脸P了上去。哦天哪，所以你丈夫出现在安迪办公室的照片里？我丈夫和五、六年前的康奈尔校友帆船队所有人。
Oh wow. I want to look for that when we watch now. Gosh, where's that picture? I can't believe you don't have that picture like framed in your house. That's amazing. As you walk into the office, it's on the bookshelf to the left, I think. I know what you're talking about. Why do I feel like if we can hunt this photo down and give it to you, you are going to give it to your husband as a gift. No.
哦，哇。我们现在看的时候要找找看。天哪，那张照片在哪里？我简直不敢相信你没有把那张照片框起来挂在家里。太棒了。当你走进办公室时，它在左边的书架上，我想。我知道你在说什么。为什么我觉得如果我们能把这张照片搜出来送给你，你就会把它当成礼物送给你丈夫。才不呢。
Oh, and then do you remember the plaque about me winding about not having a plaque? Yes. I wish I didn't take it. Why don't you have your plaque? You should have your plaque. plaque? Yes. I wish I could. Why don't you have your plaque? You should have your plaque. Right. Yes. You should have your plaque. Dang it. I have a picture of my plaque somewhere. No, I have a Dundee from Phil Shea and I have a slate from the episode I directed that Matt gave me. That's very nice. Kelly, this was wonderful. Thank you for coming and answering all these questions from a completely new perspective.
哦，还有，你还记得关于我抱怨没有牌匾的那块牌匾吗？记得。我真希望我没拿。为什么你没有你的牌匾？你应该有你的牌匾。牌匾？记得。我真希望我有。为什么你没有你的牌匾？你应该有你的牌匾。对。记得。你应该有你的牌匾。该死。我某处有一张我的牌匾的照片。不，我有一个菲尔·谢送的邓迪奖，我还有一个我执导的那集的打板，是马特给我的。太好了。凯利，这太棒了。谢谢你来回答所有这些来自全新视角的问题。
It was so interesting. I just loved talking to you and we really want you to come back for customer loyalty for the episode you directed. I'd love to. This was so wonderful. Thank you for your time and just who you were to the show and who you were to Jenna and I and still are. We love you. Thanks for having me. I love you guys. Love ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
这太有趣了。我只是喜欢和你聊天，我们真的很希望你能回来，为了你执导的那一集《客户忠诚度》再次做客。我很乐意。这太棒了。谢谢你的时间，以及你对这个节目的付出，你对珍娜和我的意义，以及现在依然如此。我们爱你。谢谢你们邀请我。我也爱你们。爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Tham Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是谭·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制片人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。